two years ago a woman named Shayla
Workman was driving in her car with her
two children aged 3 years old and
one-year-old near an apartment complex
in Nashville Tennessee and that's when a
man in his 20s Shaquille Taylor opened
fire he shot the roof of the car at
least two times as workmen drove away
and the attack was not random in fact
the motive couldn't have been clear
workmen had recently testified against
quote someone he cared about and what
was that man's crime well as Workman put
it quote his brother was locked up for
shooting at me initially in May a few
months later on August 2nd uh Taylor
found workmen at the River Chase
Apartments and also started shooting at
her quote the bullet hit the top of my
car and bounced off had I not been
driving it would have gone through the
window and shot my son in his head
authorities then arrested Taylor and he
confessed now what happened next is not
simply a scandal or a national tragedy
although it is both of those things it
is a breakdown of Law and Order that is
so Stark and so completely illogical in
every possible respect that today
members of both political parties are
calling for changes to the law in
Tennessee before more people die and
those changes and more changes need to
happen immediately as we will see this
is a problem that exists in many states
even though nobody in the media really
talks about it but it should be the
story that leads every newscast tonight
we have hit the absolute ner of BLM
mandated equity in the judicial system
and this needs to be the end of it it
just does so let's get into the the
details here Shaquille Taylor after
shooting at a moving vehicle with a
mother and her children inside
apparently in retribution for that
woman's testimony in a criminal
proceeding did not go to prison for the
rest of his life he didn't receive any
kind of lengthy prison sentence at all
for that matter in fact he received no
prison sentence sentence incredibly
Shaquille Taylor never even went to
trial instead in May of this year less
than two years after he started shooting
at Shaya workman's car Shaquille Taylor
was released from jail and his charges
were
dismissed the judge who made that
decision was Angelita black sheer Dalton
who happens to be a Democrat and also
happens to be the first black woman
elected to a judgeship in her County why
did Judge Dalton dismiss the charges
against Taylor well uh three courta
appointed doctors testified that Taylor
was supposedly too incompetent to stand
trial apparently Taylor had a
kindergarten level IQ because he
developed some kind of brain infection
as an infant and so case
dismissed now wait a minute you might
say just because someone is incompetent
to stand trial why does that necessarily
mean that they should be released from
jail this guy's shot at a moving vehicle
with children
inside and on top of that he supposedly
is mentally incompetent they're telling
us it doesn't this seem like precisely
the kind of person we don't want roaming
the
streets now as you might imagine Shayla
Workman was asking that same question
when she noticed Shaquille Taylor was
back on the streets here's what she told
local reporters quote he had a low Bond
shooting at me and my two babies at the
time and you let him out because he's
too incompetent but you can't be too
incompetent if you're admitting to
shooting at
everybody so how do we square that
Circle exactly here's the explanation
from the Associated Press which layers
on the legal le as of right now
according to the AP in order to keep
somebody like Taylor locked up under
these circumstances Tennessee Law
requires that at least two doctors
certify that Taylor's mental illness
quote causes him to be a substantial
risk of serious harm to himself or
others the doctors must also certify
that there are quote no other less
restrictive means than
commitment and apparently in this case
doctors didn't certify all of that they
didn't establish somehow a clear link
between Taylor's mental illness and his
propensity for violence and so the judge
let him go supposedly the judge had no
other
option well it didn't take long for the
consequences of the judge's decision to
become very clear a week ago on Tuesday
just about six months after his charges
were dismissed Shaquille Taylor shot and
killed an 18-year-old freshman music
student at Belmont University named
Jillian L Ludwig now Ludwig was out
walking on a track at the Edgehill
Community Memorial Gardens Park just
Steps From the campus and what is
supposed to be a nice part of the part
of town in the middle of the day you're
going for a walk you don't imagine that
your life is in any kind of Jeopardy
whatsoever but uh Jillian Ludwig's life
was in Jeopardy unbeknownst to her
because that is when Shaquille Taylor
decided to start shooting at moving
Vehicles again which as we have
discussed is something that he has a
well documented history of
doing and one of those bullets hit jilan
Ludwick she somehow laid on the track
for roughly an hour before anyone found
her even though she was very close to
police PR Precinct and shortly
afterwards she was dead
watch she was a promising Young musician
who loved to perform
I now 18-year-old Jillian Ludwick has
been senselessly killed while jogging in
a park Jillian's parents Jessica and
Matt can't make sense of what happened
just a few months ago Jillian moved from
her New Jersey home to Nashville to
study music business at Belmont
University what kind of world do we live
in where a girl just taking a jog on a
sunny day is in life-threatening danger
by a man who should not have been on the
streets Jillian was killed when a stray
bullet hit her in the head just off
campus she died two days later in the
hospital police say the shot was fired
by this man 29-year-old Shaquille Taylor
surveillance video shows the suspect
opening fire on a passing car what's
angering Jillian's parents is the fact
that just last April he was arrested for
shooting at a woman and her two kids but
the charges were dropped after he was
deemed incompetent to stand trial that
report and most reports on this case
managed to undersell Shaquille Taylor's
criminal history the shooting incident
involving the mother and her children
two children happened two years ago but
it wasn't the only serious crime that
Taylor committed according to uh local
news channel WS MV4 quote Taylor's
background also includes charges for
vehicle theft robbery handgun possession
and multiple aggravated assault charges
one affidavit said he shoved a man to
the ground back in 2015 before stealing
money from him Taylor's most recent
aggravated assault charge was in May of
this year but the DA's office did not
prosecute uh so this is not someone who
only broke the law once or twice this is
a repeat offender a repeat violent
offender Tennessee's News Channel 5 took
a closer look into why exactly he was
allowed back on the street and this is
what they report watch the order from
Judge Angelita Black Shear Dalton in May
released Taylor after hearing from three
different doctors one said he would not
understand courtroom discussions another
said he was incompetent because of his
intellectual disability and language
impairment a doctor also said Taylor
could not be involuntarily committed
because he did not seem suicidal and
repeatedly denied any homicidal
ideations or any plans to harm jail
staff or other
inmates okay so the doctor says that
Taylor denied having any homicidal
ideation or any plan to harm jail staff
or other
inmates just to remind you he tried to
kill someone like he actually did that
in real life he shot at a person but
when they asked him if he had homicidal
ideations he said no and that was good
enough to effectively exonerate him this
is how the system works now apparently
you shoot at someone and try to kill
them and then and then they ask you are
you homicidal well no I'm not well okay
then never mind to call this outrageous
would be a vast
understatement now you've heard some
excerpts from the doctor's reports that
judge Dalton relied on here's one of
them in more detail Dr Mary Elizabeth
Wood in a forensic report submitted for
the case declared that quote in my
opinion Mr Taylor does not possess
adjudicative competence due to his
intellectual disability and language
impairment you understand the
allegations and recognizes that his
Liberty interests as the accused are at
risk he was easily confused with basic
questions there was limited ability to
provide his attorney with relevant
information about his case poor guy he's
confused he doesn't understand that he
should not shoot at a woman and her
children so let's just release him back
on the street where he can shoot at more
people if you're looking for a killer
Black Friday deal I've got one for you a
free moto 5G phone from Pure Talk no
gimmicks no trading necessary just sign
up for Pure Talk's unlimited talk
unlimited text and 15 gig data you can
get all this for just 35 bucks and
you'll get the Moto G 5G phone for free
the new Moto G 5G uh phone boths a
two-day battery life an exceptional quad
pixel camera and a whole lot more this
is a great deal but you'll need to move
fast because these phones will be sold
out by the end of the month so if your
current phone is on the way out upgrade
for free with P talk P talk gives you
America's most Dependable 5G Network at
half the price so make the switch today
just go to P talk.com Walsh to get this
exclusive offer and select the plan
that's right for your family that's Pur
talk.com Walsh to claim your free Moto
g5g phone with a qualifying plan again
that's Pur talk.com Walsh Pure Talk
simply smarter
Wireless we're led to believe that judge
Dalton had no choice but to accept this
kind of utterly insane
conclusion this guy who just committed
attempted
murder understands the accusations
against against him but because he can't
grasp some ba grasp some basic questions
he needs to be released and there's just
no other option we're
told that's the official line anyway but
it doesn't appear to actually be true a
year ago a forensic psychologist at
Vanderbilt University gave an interview
with News Channel 5 in Nashville and in
the interview the psychologist a woman
named Kimberly Brown explained that
legal standards involved in these
decisions about competency also very
much involved the judges discrep
they have a lot of discretion in this
case let's listen to her explain it we
offer our opinions and recommendations
to the court it it is the judge or the
jury who ultimately decides whether the
person is insane at the time of the
crime and the judge is the one who
ultimately decides whether somebody is
competent or not but having said that I
I do appreciate that experts opinions
and reports hold significant weight and
most of the time especially with
competency the judge is going to side
with the evaluator and uh if if we say
that they're not competent find that the
person is incompetent but ultimately
that decision does rest with the judge
for competency and judge or jury for the
insanity well that makes a little more
sense according to the psychologist the
medical experts give their opinions
about whether a defendant is competent
or not to stand trial and although it's
not stated in that clip those same
medical experts also make a
determination about whether or not the
defendant poses a risk to the community
But ultimately the those medical experts
do not dictate what the judge can do
judges under the law in the state of
Tennessee have some
discretion could that be related to the
problem here well let's see judges in
Nashville like judges and so many other
Urban centers happen to be committed
leftists who are mainly interested in
equity Dalton is no exception as I
mentioned she's a Democrat she also
recently headlined events about
empowering women and increasing quote
diversity in the
profession and as it turns out her
ruling on Shaquille Taylor isn't
remotely consistent with the rulings of
other judges who have accept accepted
guilty pleas from this same guy recently
watch we took a look at the rest of his
criminal history and found two cases in
which he was charged with assault and
contributing to the delinquency of a
minor and in those cases he was able to
plead guilty to lesser charges so we're
now looking into how Taylor was able to
plead guilty several times in the past
but later deemed mentally incompetent
okay so did you catch that if you pull
up Taylor's rap sheet which dates back
to 2015 you'll find that he's pled
guilty to several serious felonies
including assault uh contributing to the
delinquency of a minor and other
felonies as well those felonies were
adjudicated back in 2016 judge dalon was
not the judge neither of those cases as
far as I can tell from public records
one of those cases was handled by judge
Samuel Coleman the other was handled by
judge Casey Morland both of those judges
are Democrats as well but in neither of
those cases was Taylor determined to be
in incapacitated so his his guilty plea
took
effect now to be clear Taylor was
supposedly disabled from birth due to an
infection when he was born so there's no
conceivable reason to think that he
suddenly developed a disability in 2023
that he didn't have in
2016 the only possible way to explain
this discrepancy is that the standard
that's operative in these cases is
subjective to the point of
incoherence so criminals like Shaquille
Taylor can go in front of some this
judge who cares about equity and they
get out of jail with no punishment even
while other judges have already
determined that he is competent enough
to accept guilty pleas multiple times
during his lengthy career as a
criminal speaking of that career just a
few weeks ago on September 21st Taylor
was arrested in a grocery store parking
lot this is a whole other crime we're
talking about now just to be clear and
in this crime he was arrested in a
grocery store parking lot driving a Ford
F-150 that had been carjacked a couple
days earlier prosecutors charged him
with felony auto theft but then a judge
led him out of jail on just a $20,000
bond this is after he shot at the mother
in her car and after he was caught in
the stolen
F-150 of course Taylor then missed his
court appearance and went on to kill a
college freshman so the point here is
that you know the system they didn't
just let Taylor slip through the cracks
no the system went out of its way again
and again and again to ensure that this
violent scumbag got back onto the
streets as quickly as possible these are
not people slipping through the cracks
they are pushed through the cracks they
are they are guided through the
cracks unsurprisingly given these
consistent failures of leftwing judges
to apply the law in a reasonable and
just way that values public safety law
La makers are now suggesting uh that
they're going to change the law but
they're not being very clear about how
they're going to do that it's been
suggested for example that we should
flag incompetent people on background
checks when they go to buy guns at the
store but uh that's not really going to
solve anything neither is making sure
they have supervision and mental health
care which has also been proposed when
incompetent people shoot at women in
their cars with their kids then they
need to be removed from society period
violent dangerous people must be taken
out of our communities and not returned
to them
ever that is the only solution there is
no
other this is why we used to have insane
asylums and that's why we should bring
them back in a big
way but you know whether a guy like
Shaquille Taylor goes to prison or an
asylum frankly I don't care which just
get him out of the community I don't
care where you put him as far as I'm
concerned throw him in a cave somewhere
for all I care just get him out
and wherever you put him he cannot be
allowed to endanger innocent law-abiding
contributing members of society that
needs to be the number one
priority so being nice to Shaquille
Taylor and trying to help him out that
is by far in a way a secondary
concern the first concern is making sure
that this guy cannot harm
anybody at least that's how it should
be you know what we're learning
here as everybody should realize by now
is that quote unquote compassion for
criminals is a zero sum
game compassion for them means cruelty
to normal law-abiding citizens and I'll
say that again because it's important to
understand compassion for criminals is
cruelty to the
community you see someone has to lose
ultimately either the criminal get a
harsh punishment or they
don't okay but if the criminal doesn't
get a harsh punishment then most of the
time that will mean a harsh punishment
is going to be doled out to some
innocent third party that had nothing to
do with
anything Jillian Ludwig died because the
system prioritized Shaquille Taylor over
Jillian
Ludwig it chose him over
her now she is dead and he's
alive comp passion for Shaquille Taylor
was cruelty to Jillian Ludwig and her
family the system didn't want to do the
ugly brutal thing which was to remove
Taylor from society permanently whether
he understood or not whether he was
competent or not whether he had a brain
infection or not doesn't
matter pull him out of
society and is that does that mean he's
going to suffer for the rest of his life
does that mean he's going to live a very
very difficult awful life in an asylum
or a prison somewhere
yes is that an ugly thing
yes but because it would not do
that um
instead it meant that we ended up with a
much uglier much more brutal thing we
end up with a promising young woman
lying dead on the sidewalk with a hole
in her
skull see that's the
choice either punish the guilty or
punish the
innocent you must choose one Society has
to choose one there is no third
option and to refuse the first option is
to choose the second it is that
simple now of course this is this is not
happening just in Nashville it's
happening in every major city we are
trading the lives of decent normal
productive people for the absolute dregs
of
humanity lwig was a beautiful young lady
a musician by all accounts a loving
daughter and sister the sort of person
that you want to have in your
community Shaquille Taylor is a sort of
person nobody wants in their Community
nobody wants to be around somebody like
this he contributes nothing he produces
nothing he helps no one he is nothing
but a strain on everything and everyone
around him all the
time objectively speaking the world
would be a better place if he was not in
it and yet he's still here and Jillian
lwig is gone that was the trade it is an
explicit deliberate
trade swapping out the best people for
the
worst this is what we're doing in cities
all over this
country it has to stop it cannot go on
this
way if you like to see what else I have
to say you can access my full show by
going to dailywire.com or by going to
the Matt wall Show Twitter page hope to
see you there godp speed